Alors j'ai pas mon pied de caméra mais on va se débrouiller
je veux absolument faire cette vidéo,
j'avais pas prévu de faire celle ci en vrai
Et bien voilà pour aujourd'hui mon pied de caméra est un livre
Salut à tous, hier je vous ai mis une vidéo en ligne sur mon analyse personnelle
du discours d'Hollande par rapport à la prise de pouvoir de Donald Trump
Cette analyse, comme toute analyse n'engage que moi,
avec ce que je pense être vrai et les conclusions que j'en tire.
et en fin de vidéo je faisais une hypothèse sur la manière d'écrire cette analyse politique là
ce qui n'avait rien à voir avec les signaux non verbaux
Et je faisais également référence avec humour au fait qu'il n'y avait qu'une lettre de préparer par l'Elysée
pour les félicitations
Suite à tous ça, il s'est passé quelque chose de cool
3 personnes qui sont amis et qui ont beaucoup de même centre d'intérêt que moi, qui se croisent
sont venus contre argumenter la vidéo
Alors déjà, comme je le disais.
J'ai plutôt la chance d'avoir une communauté cool et bienveillante
c'est à dire que c'est pas parti en live
c'était un échange, un vrai échange
et c'était déjà arrivé en début d'année avec quelqu'un d'autre
Je lui avais proposé de faire une vidéo ensemble et il a pas vraiment donné de suite
ce qui n'est pas très grave d'ailleurs, c'est un choix tout à fait respectable
et pourquoi j'avais proposé une vidéo, parce que dans les commentaires et par écrit c'est souvent redondant
on dit à peu près la même chose
Ça se cherche au mot prés
comme si il y avais un espèce de combat en fait
Et malgré les smileys, le moindre mot peut être très mal interprété
comme je vais vous laisser voir là, par exemple
ou plutôt ici, je pense que je vais l'insérer ici
Parmi ces 3 personnes, deux d'entre eux ont une chaîne
que je suis d'ailleurs, je suis abonné à ces  chaînes là
Signification et le Mythologue
je crois, je vous mettrai un lien dans la description
et j'ai eu le même genre de discussion mais avec quelqu'un que je connais un petit peu plus sur Facebook
et comme à chaque fois, depuis le début de l'année, quand ça se passe.
Je propose qu'on fasse une vidéo ensemble
L'idée n'est pas de dire si j'ai raison ou si j'ai tord
L'idée s'est de discuté ensemble
autour de ses sujets qui
apportent leur points de vue et leur analyses
et leur approches et que je puisse apporter la mienne
et que peut être on se retrouve sur des points ou pas du tout, en fait
on n'en sais rien
Mais qu'on puisse discuter ensemble et face à la caméra
je pense que ça pourrait être très intéressant de faire ça filmais
puisque ça vous donnerai un autre point de vue que le mien
une autre vérité que la mienne
Parce que j'ai pas de vraie vérité, j'ai juste ce que je crois moi
c'est ça que je vous dis à chaque fois
et donc si quelqu'un pense différemment,
ou peut être l'inverse ou peut être juste différemment
Je crois que ça peut être très intéressant et très important pour vous... de le voir
Donc comme je vous disais je leur ai proposé de faire ça
et pour la 1ère fois j'ai des réponses positives
alors je ne sais pas trop comment ça va s'organiser,
si tout le monde habite sur Paris ou pas
en tout cas ce que je sais c'est que je veux absolument vous faire cette vidéo avant la fin de l'année
Si d'autres personnes veulent y participer, alors forcément il faut arriver avec autre chose qu'un avis
c'est à dire des connaissances, une argumentation etc...
quelque chose d'assez construit
ça peut être des personnes, comme la personne que j'avais contacté qui faisait partie du milieu des zététiciens etc...
pour parler aussi de tout ça, de mon approche du mentalisme en spectacle
On peut parler de tout et ça va forcément être cool
et donc si je vous fais à vous cette vidéo ce soir,
c'est déjà pour vous dire
si vous avez lu les commentaires ou pas
ce qui était en train de se passer
mais ça me permet, si jamais il y avais eu le moindre doute à ce sujet un jour
que je ne prétend pas avoir une vérité absolue
je ne me place pas comme maître de... quoique ce soit
surtout sur le domaine délicat du non verbal
parce que c'est bien que du non verbal qu'on parle
On parle pas des techniques de mémoire,
d'influence psychologique ou de ce genre de chose
on parle toujours, là, à chaque fois c'est sur le non verbal
donc ça me permet de vous conseillez de garder toujours l'esprit critique
De chercher d'autres sources et même contradictoire c'est toujours très intéressant
et de vous annoncer qu'on devrait faire ça sur la chaîne
Merci à vous, d'avoir regarder cette vidéo
N'hésitez pas à la liker si cette idée là vous plait
qu'on fasse pas ça pour rien non plus
Vous pouvez aussi me dire en commentaire
si il y a des personnes en particulier que vous aimeriez inviter à cette discussion là
je ne vous promets rien, à part de les contacter au minimum
et d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'ils viennent
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner à la chaine avant de partir, si ce n'est pas déjà fait
Rendez vous demain à 17h
Tchao !